[Music
] mobile is the market leader in marketing
mobile places in latin america
currently serving more than 100
million users per month
we do many services from
pizza delivery at dinner to
traffic update
if the person is watching the
latest adventures of the gang  from monica at
play kids or buying tickets to the
party at the weekend in the acronym
our services are fundamental to
make our customers' lives
easier and more convenient and from ceac mobile and they
have inserted a very competitive edition
has the right tools the essentials
for subversion  in this market where it started
using the google cloud platform it only
communicates basics today it is the main
tool our operation in the video that
google can platform tasks that used to
take days now takes seconds
so this has totally changed
the way we operate
our goal is to improve  the lives of a
billion people
we are confident that with the google
cloud platform  but we will expand even
further by improving management, making
our processes more agile and reducing
costs
[Music]
[Applause]